we have now learned that jared
kushner donald trump's son-in-law made a
deal with russia
for ventilators during the coronavirus
crisis in order to be able to say hey
we've gotten ventilators we got
ventilators
it turns out every single ventilator we
got from russia
was faulty according to a new report
every aspect of this story is crazy so
first of all
it's crazy that jared kushner donald
trump's son-in-law
is working in the administration it's
insane for reasons of nepotism
it's insane for reasons of kushner's
incompetence then you might remember
that at some point in
maybe it was april or may i don't know
they trotted out jared kushner to do a
coronavirus press briefing and it went
horribly wrong
we never saw him again this was the
briefing where kushner
dropped this kafka-esque line of you
know the ventilator supply is our supply
it's not the state supply which is like
you know what we discussed that in
detail at the time
it was indecipherable evil genius and we
never saw him again at the press
briefings but even more importantly
some of the things that kushner was
doing uh
were laughably counterproductive so for
example kushner
organized getting a shipment of
ventilators from russia to the u.s
in late march they were faulty they
didn't work
andrew cuomo got some of them other
officials got them
and they started seeing supplies come in
from russia and they they were wondering
why are we getting russian supplies
and the ventilators were faulty jared
kushner was able to hurry up the
delivery
of faulty ventilators because he has a
personal relationship
with the ceo of a russian sovereign
wealth fund
currently sanctioned by the united
states so
another insane detail kushner got us
faulty ventilators more quickly
by doing business with a russian dude
who's currently under sanctioned by the
united states
every aspect of this is insane then they
gave the ventilators to officials in new
york and new jersey including andrew
cuomo the official said these don't work
and initially they said well it's just
that there's a voltage issue
because these are russian ventilators
once we fix the voltage voltage issue
it'll be fine
turns out that wasn't true the
ventilators were completely
faulty and this would be a comedy of
errors
if people's lives weren't depending on
it the shipment from russia
listen to this insanity the shipment
from russia came with other supplies
that weren't even hospital supplies like
for example
trump talks about getting gloves we're
talking about surgical gloves
medical grade gloves russia sent us
household
cleaning gloves understand that okay
just household cleaning gloves and
russia build the u.s
six hundred thousand dollars for those
gloves in the middle of a hundred year
pandemic
for which donald trump was completely
unprepared he
starts buying faulty incorrect medical
supplies
from russia now there are also reports
of more than 50 million dollars worth of
contaminated
coronavirus tests from the united arab
emirates
so the reason we elected this guy
was supposedly that a businessman would
do really well running the country now
trump is a failed businessman
okay but this is how it all works and
quite frankly
this is all seeming more like money
laundering than anything else now back
to the russian ventilators for a second
russia sent us 45
faulty ventilators around april 1 which
we paid for
we later heard news that the trump
administration was sending
putin 200 of our ventilators
as part of a foreign aid like we just
gave them to him so think about that we
buy
50 ventilators or 45 ventilators from
russia which are faulty
and then we give them 200 of our
ventilators which work well
this is how a businessman runs the
country is it money laundering
is it embezzlement and this is just one
story among hundreds like this
in this administration we may never know
the full reality of it and you know what
if we get rid of them i don't care if we
never know the full reality of every
single one of these stories